the seven healthiest foods you should be
eating on a daily basis. And I'm also
going to give you three additional bonus
foods that will complete your entire
diet. Most unhealthy foods on the planet
raise your insulin, which is called
insulin resistance, is at the root of
probably 80% of chronic disease out
there. In other words, most foods that
lower insulin are good, and the foods
that raise insulin are super bad for
you. So, one of the common themes
throughout this list is going to be
foods that do not increase your insulin.
Okay? And there are no other foods that
I know that will even come close to
these seven or we say 10 foods. So,
let's start with number one, sauerkraut.
You want to make sure you get raw
sauerkraut because if you buy sauerkraut
in the store that's on the shelf that is
pasteurized which means it's heated and
heat or pasteurization is going to
destroy the key thing in sauerkraut
which is the microbes. Did you realize
that sauerkraut is one of the most
powerful probiotics out there? Way
better than yogurt, way better than
kefir, and way better than most
probiotics that you buy from the grocery
store. One cup of this fermented cabbage
provides like 1.9 net carbs. So, it
barely has any carbs at all. It's a lot
of fiber, but a lot of nutrition.
Sauerkraut is the most vitamin C dense
food out there. In one tiny cup, you're
going to get over 700 mg of vitamin C.
That is 10 times the RDA, okay? Just
from one little cup. It's a very easy
vegetable to digest. Most people with
digestive problems, especially if they
have an ulcer or gastritis, can consume
sauerkraut very easily. Sauerkraut also
is loaded with something called
glutamine, which actually heals the gut
if there's inflammation. Sauerkraut also
is loaded with vitamin K2. Vitamin K2
removes calcium from the soft tissues of
the body, including the arteries,
including calcium that builds up in your
joints. And so apparently the microbes
in this sauerkraut make vitamin K2. It's
pretty wild. Sauerkraut also is loaded
with all sorts of phytonutrients. One
being sulfurophane, which normally
people think about in broccoli or
broccoli sprouts, but it's also in other
cruciferous vegetables like sauerkraut,
which is basically cabbage. It's not
only been studied as having anti-cancer
properties, but also can help to put
this microbe called H. pylori back in
remission. This is the microbe behind
ulcers. The real heavy lifter on the
sauerkraut is something called vitamin
U. The technical name for it is
smethylmethionine.
This specific nutrient heals ulcers.
It's great for inflammation in the
stomach. But if you have any type of
ulcers in your stomach, in your small
intestine, in the large intestine, it
goes in there and it builds up the
mucous layer and it actually heals an
ulcer. I would just put like a half a
cup or maybe even one cup on your plate
and that's all you need per day. All
right, let's go to number two. Arugula
is one of those vegetables that has very
low amounts of oxalates. Oxalates can
aggravate the joints. They can end up as
kidney stones, but arugula is a very
safe vegetable if you're concerned about
kidney stones. But the big reason you
want to consume arugula as your
alternative lettuce for your salad is in
what it can do for the inside of your
arteries. It's one of those foods that
gives you the highest amount of nitric
oxide. Okay. Now, what is nitric oxide?
Nitric oxide is a very special compound
to help vasoddilate the arteries to keep
the blood pressure from going high to
help protect the arteries against
inflammation. And I'm not just talking
about the circulation around the heart.
I'm talking about circulation throughout
the entire body. So, it's not just good
for blood pressure. It's also good for
erectile dysfunction. And out of all the
foods in the planet, arugula has the
most nitric oxide. The other cool thing
about arugula is it has anti-cancer
properties because it's a cruciferous
vegetable. And of course, I dump a lot
of extra virgin olive oil on arugula.
And personally, I also add a little
nutritional yeast on it because it gives
it a little cheese flavor. And
nutritional yeast gives you B vitamins,
amino acids. And so the combination of
why I take it is it tastes good and also
it gives me more B vitamins, especially
to keep the stress low. Number three,
wild caught salmon. Wildcaugh is kind of
like the equivalent of organic. You're
going to get something a lot better than
farm rays because with farm rays
sometimes they use antibiotics.
Sometimes they'll use certain additives
that you don't want in that fish. And
also they have to use like different
pigments to color the salmon to make it
look pink. But when you're consuming
wild caught salmon, it's just super
healthy because it's out in the wild.
Just 3 ounces of salmon equal 2,000
milligrams of omega-3 fatty acids. Now,
what is an omega-3 fatty acid? It's a
combination of two things. DHA, which is
really good to build your brain and your
retina to allow you to see, as well as
EPA, which is a very powerful
anti-inflammatory. So, anything related
to itis, arthritis, berscitis,
tendonitis, inflammation of whatever,
you want more omega-3 fatty acids. So,
if we actually compare salmon, fish to
cod fish, okay? Salmon, and we're
talking about 3 ounces. Salmon will give
you 2,000 milligs of omega-3. Cod only
gives you 171 milligrams. Now, I'm not
talking about cod liver oil. I'm talking
about the fish cod. Now, some people are
concerned about mercury when they
consume fish. Well, you don't have to be
with salmon because salmon is loaded
with something called selenium. Selenium
helps bind with the mercury and helps
mobilize it out of the body so it
doesn't build up. And further down the
list, when I talked about another food
with selenium, it's going to blow your
mind. One thing about salmon that I
always do is I always eat it with the
skin on it. Okay, the skin has a lot of
nutrients, especially right underneath
the skin. you have a lot of omega-3
fatty acids and you have other things
too like collagen. So, I would highly
recommend you do salmon or other fatty
fish at least a couple times a week.
Now, I did mention cod, but I didn't
mention cod liver. Okay, now what is cod
liver? Cod liver is something you can
consume in a can. You can buy it online
through Amazon or another way, but they
actually sell cod liver in a can versus
going to the grocery store trying to
find it. probably not going to find it.
So, cod liver is the liver of the cod
fish. And cod liver is very unique
because out of all the foods, including
salmon, cod liver has the most omega-3
fatty acids. And omega-3 is so important
right now, not just for your heart, just
to drive inflammation down, to counter
all the high omega-6 fatty acids from
the seed oils, because omega-3 compete
for omega6. And so the majority of the
population consumes like 1/3 of their
calories, seed oils. And so we need a
lot more omega-3 to balance that out.
And if we're talking about
nutrient-dense foods, yes, you have
organ meats, you have liver and things
like that. A lot of people don't like
those organ meats, especially liver,
including myself. Even though it's good
for me and I want to like it, I just
can't eat it. But I can do cod liver.
It's like pudding. I like the texture. I
like the taste. So, there's some unique
things about cod liver. Okay, first of
all, it comes in cod liver oil, which is
another thing super high in omega-3, but
I wouldn't actually drink the oil or
your gallbladder is going to feel very
heavy. So, I would just eat the cod
liver in the oil and not drink the oil.
But, if I were to compare cod liver to
salmon, cod liver has a lot more omega3
and it's fattier, too. But the fat that
you get is very very good for your
brain, for your nervous system, and for
your heart. And just as a side note, the
two things that don't increase insulin,
fiber, which is in here, and here, and
fat. Okay, so that would be fatty
salmon, and cod liver, which is fattier
than a lean fish. Several years ago, I
did a video on canned products like
this. And in my mind, I thought, I
assumed without testing, if you heated
these foods up like they do that would
destroy the omega-3 fatty acids. Okay,
that was in my mind. Never tested it.
So, I did a video on that. And then I
felt a little weird about it because I
didn't really do a test on it. So, I
went to the grocery store. I bought some
canned tuna. I bought some cod liver. I
bought some canned sardines and I sent
them to the lab because I wanted to see
if the test aligned with what they were
claiming. The report came back and I was
like, "Wow,
it actually does have the amount of
omega-3s that they say it does." And so
I deleted the other video, did a new
video, and talked about that you can
still retain omega-3 fatty acids with
the heat that they do in the canning
process. Number five, hamburger.
Probably is surprising you, right?
You're probably thinking hamburger is a
junk food. Thinking about, well, you go
to McDonald's, you buy a hamburger. I'm
not talking about that hamburger, okay?
That hamburger has meat in it from
probably two or 300 different sources.
The quality is not that great. I'm
talking about a grass-fed hamburger. If
you could find organic, that would be
even better. But grass-fed hamburger is
not only easy to digest, but it normally
has a little more fat to protein. I
would not buy the lean one. I would buy
the one that's like an 8020, a little
bit fattier because of this. If you
consume lean meat, you're going to raise
a little more insulin than if it was
more fat with that protein. Same thing
with eggs. If you're doing the egg
whites without the yolk where the fat
is, you're going to have a higher spike
in insulin. In fact, out of all the
types of protein that you can eat, the
protein that is the highest on the
insulin scale is whey protein powder
because it's super low fat. There's no
fat in whey protein. It's just pure
protein. So, what I recommend is that
you consume protein with the fat that
normally comes with that protein. So,
it's you're not going extra lean or low
fat at all. You're going to find when
you eat that protein with the fat, it's
going to stay in your digestive system a
little bit more and you're going to get
more absorption from the amino acids,
it's not going to go through your body
as fast because it's less refined. It's
more natural. I consume a lot of
hamburger, of course, without the bun.
It just makes me feel good. All this
data about red meat that people tell you
causes cancer, diabetes is utterly
ridiculous. It's absolutely not true. In
fact, I healed my body on red meat.
Okay, red meat, especially from animals
that eat grass, is super high quality.
It's very bioavailable. Hamburger also
has a lot of other things, not to
mention the B vitamins, zinc, iron,
copper. It also has something called
carnosine. And carnosine is like an
anti-aging
antioxidant compound that just helps you
live longer. Hamburger is also high in
creatine. So people buy creatine all the
time as a powder to increase their
muscle growth. And so when you eat
hamburger, you're getting like 350
milligrams per 100 grams. And hamburger
will give you the type of iron that is
the most bioavailable on Earth. Right?
If you get iron from spinach, you're not
going to even get close to the
absorption as you would from meat.
Number six, Brazil nuts. I wouldn't
recommend consuming a lot, one or two
per day. Now, what the heck is so
special about a Brazil nut? Well, out of
all the food on planet Earth, Brazil
nuts have the most selenium of any food
on planet Earth. So, the next question
is, what's so special about selenium?
First of all, it can help your thyroid
help T4 convert to T3, the active form
of the thyroid hormone. A lot of people
with hypothyroidism,
not that they don't have enough iodine,
it's they don't have enough selenium
because it's not very prevalent in the
soils. It's not in the food like it used
to be. A lot of the fertilizers that we
use don't let selenium go into the
plant. And if it's not in the plants or
the animals, it's not going to end up in
our bodies. So, if you suffer from a
selenium deficiency, the thyroid is
going to suffer number one. But number
two, and this is a big one, this is
huge. If you've checked out on my video,
just check back in right now because
this is like the most important part of
this entire video. What selenium does
for your immune system is mindblowing.
Certain tea cells, specifically the T
helper cells, cannot work without
selenium. T- helpper cells. That's like
the command center of your immune
system. That is like the Pentagon over
the military. If you don't have that
high level control to tell the troops to
deliver certain weaponry against certain
pathogens, viruses, and cancer, then
you're going to be very vulnerable and
susceptible to having problems like
AIDS, for example. AIDS is a condition
where you don't have your immune system.
Did you realize there's a huge
correlation between selenium deficiency
and susceptibility to AIDS? And there's
also a lot of data by increasing
selenium and improving the complications
of AIDS. One of the most common
conditions on planet Earth right now,
which is autoimmune diseases, and
there's a lot of them. Hashimoto's,
lupus, rheumatoid arthritis, MS. These
people with these conditions are
suffering from either a selenium
deficiency or a vitamin D deficiency.
Both of them work hand in hand. A lot of
men and women who have low selenium have
problems with testosterone. Realize if
you're a female, testosterone turns into
estrogen. The estrogen that you have
comes from testosterone. And also,
selenium protects the ovary to help
someone become more fertile. It protects
the testicle to be able to make the
sperm more mobile. Selenium is also
crucial in preventing your hair from
falling out. And even think about a very
common problem with hair loss, which is
alopecia. That's an autoimmune disease.
Selenium can greatly help that. Now,
there's a problem with toxicity with
selenium if you have like 20 nuts every
day for months. So, I'm only
recommending you do one or two Brazil
nuts every day.
Extra virgin olive oil. First of all,
it's going to help you extract a lot of
the phytonutrients from the salad you
put it on if you're going to use arugula
or romaine or leafy greens. The way that
you know it's the real extravirgin olive
oil is you'll feel a little tickle
biting sensation in the back of your
throat. I've consumed olive oil for
years and I didn't know that because I
was consuming probably an adulterated
version which wasn't even the real
thing. You just buy at the grocery
store. It's really cheap and there's a
lot of corruption with olive oil. They
mix it with different things. So, you
really have to just find a good brand
that comes from either Spain or Italy or
other countries, but I consume a lot of
olive oil. It's good for your heart.
It's good for your cells. It works as an
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant. And
the phytonutrients are 20 times stronger
than green tea. It's also really good
for the mitochondria, okay? The little
energy factories in your cell. It's
anti- clotting. Realize this, 90% of
heart attacks are related to a blood
clot, not plaquing.
Same thing with the stroke. So,
extravirgin olive oil is really
important to have in your diet. Now,
let's give you the bonus foods. Cheese.
I'm talking about quality cheese. Full
fat cheese, raw cheese, aged cheese.
Most of the cheese that I consume, I get
it imported from another country. But
that's not 100% because there are
certain places in America that are doing
it right. But cheese is a fermented
product. So there's microbes in there.
It's good for your gut, but cheese also
is loaded with vitamin K2. Vitamin K2
from my viewpoint is an anti-aging
vitamin on steroids. It keeps the
calcium from building up in the soft
tissues in your arteries as well as
keeping the calcium from building up in
your joints. And as you're aware of,
when we get older, we calcify. We become
very, very stiff filled with calcium,
not just in the joints and the arteries,
but also even in our eyes and other
tissues. The other thing that cheese has
is something called CLA. It's a very
interesting compound that can help you
burn more fat. So, we have cheese as a
probiotic. It has butyric acid that can
help feed our colon cells. And cheese is
fermented. And so it eats up all the
milk sugar lactose. So it's very low
carb. It's a high quality protein. The
next bonus, chocolate. Now, I'm not
talking about Hershey's chocolate
kisses. I'm talking about dark
chocolate. But you can actually do
cacao, which is a powder, and you can
mix that in something and take that,
which I do that as well. But sometimes
I'll get 85%
dark chocolate as my dessert for the
first meal right around lunch. I don't
consume chocolate late at night because
it has certain type of stimulants. But
what's in chocolate is amazing. It's
loaded with polyphenols. It'll increase
your nitric oxide, that compound that's
a vasod diilator in the arteries that
helps your circulation just like
arugula. But the more I study this dark
chocolate, I'm just the more I'm just
it's mind-blowing on all the different
cool effects that it has. Some people
will say you better not consume this
dark chocolate because it's high in
oxalates and oxalates can lead to kidney
stones. But there's one mineral, it's
loaded in chocolate that has high
affinity for these oxalates and it can
connect to neutralize oxalates and that
is magnesium. Magnesium is one of the
master controllers of calcium, keeping
calcium in check. Magnesium is very
deficient in a lot of people. Magnesium
helps your muscles. It helps lower
cortisol. It helps your sleep and it
helps you create more energy in your
mitochondria. And a lot of people that
think they're craving chocolate really
aren't craving chocolate. Your microbes
are craving chocolate. And it's sending
signals to the brain, eat chocolate. And
yes, there is a small amount of sugar,
but there's like six net grams of carbs,
which is on the low side because if
you're in the ketogenic diet, you want
it below 50. So, an extra six is not too
bad. You can pretty much go for a walk
and burn that off very easily. The last
bonus, El Rutderai yogurt. Now, what is
that? Well, I'm going to put a video
down below so you can learn how to make
this. You'll need a yogurt maker. If you
don't want to bother with that, then
maybe just do Bulgarian yogurt, which is
also pretty good. But there's something
very special about Eluterai yogurt that
I want to explain. Eluterie as a microbe
is something that's missing in the
general population. We just don't have
it anymore. Especially if you've never
been breastfed, especially if you've had
antibiotics, you don't have it. And so,
it's such a key microbe because it helps
increase muscle mass. It helps your
sleep. It helps with increasing this
hormone called oxytocin.
Oxytocin is one of the most powerful
hormones that lowers cortisol and stress
and it increases
social impulses. So, in this video, I
show you how to make it yourself and we
make it. We keep it in the fridge. And
when I first started making it, I
started taking it and about a week
later, my wife's like, "What the heck
has gotten into you?" I go, "What do you
mean?" She goes, "You want to like hug
me five times a day? Like, you never
want to hug me. What is wrong with you?
Keep eating the yogurt." I said, 'Okay,
I will. Good thing it's my wife's
around. But it's pretty wild. This
eldery actually creates that effect. But
really, it's the microbe that's sending
a signal through the vagus nerve all the
way up to our brain to tell something in
our brain to make more. It doesn't
actually give you more oxytocin. It
triggers your body to make more. Isn't
that wild? A lot of people have small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth, SIBO,
and that's where you get a lot of
bloating in the small intestine. So, a
lot of the microbes that should be in
the large intestine end up in the small
intestine. And every time you eat, you
just feel really bloated. And all you
need is like a half a cup a day. Most
people are eating the opposite of these
foods, okay? They're eating refined
foods. I want you to eat these foods
just for seven days to prove it to
yourself. You will feel the best you've
ever felt ever just by trying this. So,
please in the comment tell me you're
going to try this tomorrow because you
have to prepare for it and then come
back in seven days and tell me how you
feel. Before I go, I want to give you my
daily reboot routine that I do every
single day in a one-page document.
Presently I am 60 years old. I actually
feel like I am 18. I am way healthier
now than I was when I was in my 30s.
Okay? Like by a factor of 10x. Now once
you've done that, I have another video
that I want you to watch. And this one
is how to make that eluterai yogurt. And
for that information, watch this video
right here.